- So your, your first date,
first of all, I always find it funny
when people go to the
movies on their first date,
but I think it was a movie
because it's always like,
well, we're not gonna talk the whole time
'cause we're in a movie.
(laughing)
I always found it funny
when everybody was like
- That's true.
- when people ask me out,
they're like, you want to go to a movie?
And I'm like, well, I don't know,
do you want to actually talk to me?
(laughing)
But, but it is a normal thing
- Yeah.
- to go to the movies
and I'm curious, what was that movie?
What was the first date movie night like?
- You know, I, I kind of forget.
I mean.
- Yeah.
You're like it's minute,
it's been like 47 years.
- Yeah.
43 years, yeah.
But, well, what's the last
movie you saw together?
- Oh, the last movie we
actually saw on Friday,
it was Land.
It's the new movie out with Robin Wright.
- Oh, I love her.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, she was great.
So she goes out into the
wilderness and survives
and it's a beautiful
movie, you should see it.
- I am so into that,
- Okay.
- I'm like all into
those kinds of books as well.
- Yeah.
- Like emergency, no stress,
like all that stuff, I--
- Wild.
- Yeah I love, yeah agreed, agreed.